thank you to both rocket money and hellofresh
for sponsoring this video more on them after
the reaction [Music] people citizens of the
reacher Nation Oh did it we are here today to
kickoff Reacher season 2 episode one John how
pumped are you it would be a reach to say I'm
not jacked about this G that's some Allen tck
that's right my bad I'm on the tck path you
know he's got some buff the citizens please go
ahead leave a like on this video that would mean
a lot also subscribe click the notification Bell
to get notified when our reaction for episode 2
is up on the channel if you didn't catch or
Reacher reactions for season 1 they are of
course here thank you to prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights and as usual a full
length Reaction watch along where you sync up with
your own copy of Reacher with us as available for
super sex Rex over at our patreon page and over
there John and I cover several things exclusively
with highlights and watch Longs included any who
John you're ready so ready let's do this let's do
[Music]
it ooh cat skills huh I would love to
go there I'm a Catman I'm a Catman I'm a
cat damn I didn't even see a Traer for
this I have no idea what we're store
for yeah what's the setting I mean
I guess we're gonna be in New York
but wo whoa that is a
body whoa is he just thrown out oh
he was thrown out ain't no shoot
jeez is that Jack that's Jack it's Jack
sleeper flat Reacher Jack Jack for a
second oo they didn't catch the name of that
title I know they they just assume we pause
everything Arkansas hey it's a c after
going cat skill we're going to cat
luck what am I supposed to do with
these what him and sell them oh thft
you buying anything Jack bearder jeans
t-shirt jacket socks boxers God he is
massive now I know he got fat yes he
let himself go what a fat ass fat reer
$222 11 yeah Doug was supposed to
take that down a few days ago if you
knew they were supposed to come down
why didn't you do it cuz it's Doug's
job and this is now false advertising
and I can beat the [__] out of you
oh thil sorry I have to make another withdrawal
oh who gave you that Shiner well hit her Jack
she's taking forever yeah or at least beat
up the vending machine vending machine the
ATM I'm sorry it's a money vending machine
you know don't turn around I can help you
that minivan on my left that yours oh oh
oh she's kidnapped you've been carjacked
right ah yes my child is in the back seat
that is a hell of a shot damn yeah stay
here this won't take long oh Jack Reacher
has the best save the cat moments your mom
better hurry the up kid this is going to go
bad for both one shot yeah what was that oh
yes just snapped his rib cage up the middle
now take your shirt off yeah wow hi want to
see your mom it's okay you want to see your
mom go in the bank call the cops give them
these who are you someone who prefers not
getting involved okay who's going to pay
for my window I would have at least taken
some money from her yes the negatives did
he get like a fat deposit Maybe here's 30 need
a new jacket what's wrong with the one you just
bought it has blood on it can I use your phone
I just got a message from a friend via the ATM
I think you got like a fat deposit I got your
message 1110th 10:30 at a stress call that is
a fat deposit yeah this is just message money
we set aside for sending messages Tammy Kates
let me guess bank teller Dino waitress drift
shop cashier Calvin France was murdered I'll
let you know when I land uhoh these damn
personal connections of people getting
murdered what if he didn't go to the ATM I
know what other way would the message have
gotten flashback Jack hello sir just Reacher
I didn't tell you to bring anything just some
office supplies in case there was any startup
paperwork needed to be done I hate paperwork
oh last season Mentor killed this season
pupil ooh mentees killed what exactly am
I doing here saw you a few weeks ago buy your
barracks stopped a couple soldiers and beating
the hell out of each other over a stolen care
package from home good man nice cookie in the
Box actually one cookie yeah even dumber bottom
line you negotiated a fair settlement cracked a
few jokes de-escalated the conflict got
a decent head on you you remind me of
me yes perfect guitar music cute what the hell
kind of unit did major Reacher put together here
huh we got a bean counter from accounting services
ouch gas jockey from bulk fuel we got Dave
Matthews Grandpa Moses and uh couple of guys from
uh where youall from senior requisitions right we
got names Sanchez Norco and who are you besides
the guy who talks too much David Odon oh I've got
a rule plans go to hell soon as first shots been
fired so your first shot better be your best shot
I'm the only non-marine to win the USMC thousand
yard Invitational and I still know Lowry gives us
our best first shot you think this unit's going to
come under a lot of fire maybe then why'd you grab
a bunch of people with no police experience major
Reacher Reacher why does any like to be called
major cuz he's not a rank guy none of that matters
out there Army wanted a unit for particularly
complex matters when they arose to do that I need
special investigators if we're so special why do
they stick Us in this dump a few years ago Uncle
Sam made an auction bid for some some land down
the road entered the address backwards became the
proud owners of this building in the contents of
the now defunct Callahan Insurance Agency is that
a real thing that that must have happened sometime
yeah it sounds like straighten up these boxes
move these old tanker DS in the middle of the
room got really preoccupied with it does
this work this is Jack's add kicking in
go backwards you want me to go backwards
I'm going backwards go backward damn by
season 3 Allen rich and just going
to be like a tiny head poking out of
massive shoulder muscle it's going to be
that guy from hero Academia I could use a
beer there got to be a beer pun for Jack
Reacher Jack Yorker yor creature thanks
for ordering still steam coming off the cup
track the plane online so I landed early you
don't check bags and I adjusted for traffic had
the coffee poured 90 seconds ago it's my Fifth
Fifth cup though try to time it right everything
been a minute since Mar been 2 years 7 months 19
days yeah so France I'm missing after leaving
this home in Brooklyn about a week or so ago
body was found in the Catskill Mountains well
Force up there is like 20 cops NYPD is taking
the leap how'd you find out got a call from
Angela I watch the prog of the episode fr's
Widow fron was married yeah fun wedding Fran's
wife France's Lover he had a son too life moves
on when you're away big fell France had a FR
line and a fraternal child your messages in
the days before his disappearance said he wanted
to bounce some stuff off me about a case who was
chasing down woof I kep meaning to get back to
him but before I could andela reached out and
told me he'd be murdered it's not your fault
don't do that it wasn't just murdered he was
tortured got a mucus in his stomach dehydrated
checked out of a plane an airplane has a stall
speed of what 80 mph it would have shoved him out
of the do's playe horizontally into the slipstream
he'd bang into the wing or tail there'd be Perry
morm injuries than there aren't who was thrown
from a helicopter sure yeah dumbass ENT full of
free histamines massive pain reaction that's why
Ferris oxide powder was found in his pants fabric
he was hit with a rusty iron bar in the pants he
was tortured through the revenge or information
when they were done with him they dumped him from
the sky to avoid ballistics wow he was calling
you for help he may have been trying to get in
touch with the rest of the unit probably failed
I called odonnell Dixon Sanchez and Rosco I got
to say the background actors are like exceptional
I've been looking at them the whole time New York
afternoon in a coffee show what about low killed 2
years ago in a car accident in Montana no one told
me no phone no address you could have sent me an
emergency ATM message like today it wasn't really
an emergency huh it was the moment the pickup hit
Larry and be honest would you really have traveled
all the way to Montana from Texas or Maine or
wherever you were at the time just to look at
a body in a box no ouch the thought that counts
so I'll ask again next steps let's go see Fran's
Widow yeah like like this guy wouldn't
finish the sandwich get to go box bro
like he would have just eat it on the go
get the fries for a carbo load this guy's
like full this is the diet I take to maintain
this physique three bites I'm good for the day
uhoh she just met up with the big one let's
pronounced bigan odonnell this is Reacher with
another 1030 NE and I are staying at the veil
hotel in Brooklyn get off your ass and call us
back receptionist at Dixon's office says she
can't say where Dixon is or when she'll return
probably an undercover job yeah maybe they're
all in trouble too someone's picking them off
one by one this show just got amazing I'd like a
banana I'd like a banana I was going to say this
isn't The Wiggles is is is it sorry it took me so
long to disengage it's just hard to get my sister
off the phone she calls every hour my own personal
suicide watch no sorry that was uh morbid I should
have said that after what you've been through
you can say whatever you want reel it in lady
yeah we don't want your life story can't believe
how much your son looks like franie I called him
franzy too oh I know he loved me and Mikey more
than anything but from the way he talked I don't
think he ever had any more fun than his years
spent with the 1110th yeah he hated being a dead
the real war was at home I was away with Mikey
and Provo helping my sister with our mom early
onset dementia golly I tried Calvin for a few
days and no return calls it's not like him so
I started to worry called NYPD they just said
he could have been out on a Case cuz he was a
pi or maybe he was out partying because his wife
and kid were out of town wow do you think that's
what he was doing out partying with the wrong
crowd tell him to stay in school I came back
early to find our home ransacked nothing was
taken were you aware of any cases France may
have been working on he never brought work home
when he was here he wanted to be 100% present
for me what a good guy seems like her life was a
living hell but she had a great husband yeah the
most baggage with family but my hobby were
any other members of the 110th working with
him I don't know maybe there's something in his
office there you go a sign on the door is Three
Rivers Consulting and Associates it's 103 flat
Bush what franzy always told me was the special
investigators weren't any ochre but cops you do
not mess with the special investigators o spooky
creepy child what are you drawing kid yeah what
scribbly demonic image if you conjured over there
I'm pretty sure that black sedan halfway down the
street was outside the diner too there's a black
sedan on never Street in America yeah but this
is different punch the window Jack come on no
the neth checking in under the name Sarah Connor
and uh paying for an adjoining room using the name
staring Castro must be for the Hulk staring
Castro played for the Yankees Robert Patrick
hey did you know he was in this no idea perfect
though and who's Sarah Conor just keep an eye on
that hotel and they said Sarah Conor yeah oh my
God and he played Sarah Connor yes get it I yeah
oh my God I can't believe they really got her
very modest for a guy with Wall Street business
close to home so we can spend more time with his
family exact kind of place fronie would choose
checks out no and they left pissed they were
looking for anything behind this glass window
but they put that phone through it that's an act
of frustration by someone who didn't find what
they wanted he hey good psychological
profiling Sherlock Reacher seems like
yesterday a partying with us you're supposed to
protect him jack ke yeah what do you see you have
to put it in a place that was very secure but
readily available somewhere in plain sight that
we see every day but a place no one would suspect
so it's a place that's readily available that we
entrust every day with very important items
a door knob this is a mailbox key oh [__]
I ever tell you you're smart Ney not not nearly
enough not nearly enough I don't want to watch
a show political messages about why post offices
still exist in the era of Amazon yeah yeah come
on big post office paid for the show Prime video
doeser show 10,000 combinations if it's a four
number code oh he can figure it out hey get some
passwords we have to come back tomorrow so what
do we do now I figured out the password yeah I
mean I'm expecting that wholeheartedly I'm like
he would do it this way and it would lead him to
these numbers if you let me win I'm going to be
pissed I don't let you win I pce myself waffle
crisp not in your professional life rental cars
a Range Rover killer hotel rooms sent me airfare
like it was nothing you're doing well this feels
like a fantasy clearly not pacing yourself in
your professional life but the term wonderin
has been tossed around the office two promotions
in the past two years hey it's not just about the
money feels good I just take the money yeah I
don't need the money see with anyone else no
did you talk to anyone at the game you think about
going to margrave during the game more lonely than
ever when you went out to get gas I tried everyone
again radio silence you should try the phone next
time that's weird they all responded in the group
chat we I've been talking to everyone for hours
instead of leaving a voicemail there's someone to
actually talk to right because we just established
how much you like talking to people up gab Reacher
it was always obvious you guys had a think for
each other did you ever sleep together or chat
Reacher no wouldn't have been appropriate you were
the same rank I ran the team oh so look at you
you work out so much because you got testosterone
spreading throughout your entire system this is
your entire essence of being night Neely night
Reacher oh that was a really cool transition I'm
going to get a men's room door for my bedroom
flashing back so whenever we're in the present
day there's kind of a blue lighting and then
whenever we're in the past it's a green lighting
if you don't mind me asking who directed you to
feel this team S I do mind you calling me sir
you're not supposed to be drinking in uniform
uh oh we're not drinking we were drinking then you
interrupted us it's the Army do any of us really
belong here ouch some kind of smart guy smarter
than you people leave me and my pals alone I
leave them alone they don't I don't I thought his
rule was plants go to hell when the first shots
fir there's a lot of rules for different situ
finish my beer and I'll be on my way okay sir
how about you be quiet your adult's talking wow
dude man what is your beef I'm not understanding
some of this uh hostility yeah what's going
on here I'm providing you an opening because
I promise my mother I'd give dumb guys like you
a chance to walk away we got 12 oh you got nine
so it's a warm-up round for reach yeah well
that's a shame you were at least three short
yep Boogie steps right through oh
my God don't give us and that's how
they bond it as a unit yeah that's
how they become a single organism
[Music] he hired all those guys yeah hey list
well let's just kick your asses for one night
and then we'll bring so much business to your bar
I promise I need these people to work together
shouldn't have been at the officer's Club I
know and why get into a fight over it he did
n nicely a you and I are gonna be Pals we reach
her you're big softy you already are da you're
going to be my series regular tonight the boys of
the 91st learned a very important lesson that you
do not mess with the special investigators you do
not with the special investigators you tell your
future children this yes you knew that was going
to happen tonight I knew the 91st like to drink
on Thursday nights and that they're sticklers
for the rules and that they're [__] I know
they can all work together get yourself a common
eny photo op to commemorate our first date as a
unit you fire how would I just take it this is
the photo dude my God it's all coming together
okay guys 4 seconds oh take it easy on your
osteoporosis kiss my ass Young Blood kiss my
osteoporosis after I take a leak you're about to
get a little taste of Crocodile Rock I only know
Elton John hey Reacher they talked me from the
helicopter Reacher whoa what are you going to
do about it oh damn flashback so he saw that in
the yes he had a premonition it was planted there
like a memory but it was really a premonition
but he wasn't able to get lock it until right
now reason for your visit Mr Mount I'm here to
sightsee Universal Studios Walk of Fame man's
Chinese you I'm bit of an old Hollywood fanatic
anything to declare I have nothing to declare
oh blue mask took 12 takes for him to get that
right yeah back to one back to K just throw it
walk up to it like a normal human being you
got to get the pages to Splash when they go
in what buddy wow he's so badass he does at the
airport doesn't even wait to get to a place more
discreet than this can't have anyone catch
me with his passport I'm the way out of the
airport where everyone has a passport Angela has
no idea which PO Box belonged to Calvin and the
post office won't give her that information until
the estate's been settled because the box was in
his company's name right right right of course
we can't just go in there and start trying boxes
like 89% of the world FRS is right-handed so
he' probably ask for a box on the right when
you enter he gets public records sent to him
surveillance photos so he's going to need one
of the big boxes I'll start with him I just need a
distraction okay okay just going to get naked yes
you know now he's distracted whoa I can't focus
on the job cuz they're naked NE I am a hardcore
Fatalis and I have been fully a flutter about this
new batch of stamps that were recently issued yep
desert flowers uh state birds and the world of
anime all of them uh there's at least two dozen
of these uh cartoons if you're not familiar with
anime I believe it's Japanese God is making me
want to go get some novelty stamps States oh je
excuse me excuse me can I get to my box is that
your key yeah I just can't remember which box
is mine sir this man is using a key that isn't
his what are you the male police all good here
no sir I'm going to need some ID that ties you
to that box you know what I'll take all of them
how about that here we go no problem just got my
box is confused Jesus I bet that old lady is
the big villain of the show hiding in plain
sight my laptop has a different port I got to go
pick up an adapter do me a favor water up aide on
one of those phone app things oh I need to borrow
your car you know France was killed over this hard
drive and now you want to go get a gun what do
I look like mac Reacher first I need to go to
church like any church is he just actually going
to church no he knows he's got to know a priest
run away I'm looking for my cousin he has a
really bad drug problem and a family friend
said they saw him living on the street around
here I'm sorry to hear that well thank you I
promised Myan I wouldn't come back home without
her son maybe the church has a support group
or something and through that maybe you'd have
some idea where Jimmy was scoring Jimmy almost
everyone who comes into our outreach program gets
their fix from the same place Dumont just east of
Rockaway but you got to have a death
wish to walk in there alone son I'll
be fine father I have righteousness
on my side sure you got the Lord at
your back you that SM this ain't no
furniture warehouse man I don't do
no credit hey I'd like to buy some drugs
this is time to clean up the streets yeah
buddy crazy mother shaking that ass
ouch cocaine oxy MTH full service
dealer oh don't mind me I'll be
taking this more variety in the
music choices this season yeah I'm liking
the needle drops for the Outreach progr
Dizzle he's like I can finally go buy the
drug I want yes always felt so conflicted
about taking it from the offering tray but
now everyone's always talking about how good
the trucks are right around the corner I
don't get to try any of that help yourself
six figure instruments in the front there's
a completely different crime happening in Los
Angeles it can shine a lighthouse on them
man water marks are flawless no one will
really know who you are get me a lighthouse
and we'll figure that out but you know whoa
dang what a dangerous profession just getting
back yeah had to go to three stores to get
what I needed you got everything I needed in
one place I know I know which one had what
you needed there's chocolate on my pillow and
all the sheets [Music] are nah n wasn't quick
enough they didn't find what they was looking for
did they there's the sign of [Music] frustration
hey it's your boy see you're still using brass
knuckles no more switchblade look down oo hey
odonald I love that Trope cuz I'm like he could
still shoot you and he wouldn't get stabbed at the
CR yeah it's a good distraction but also
a guy like re I can't shoot him he'll
definitely stab me on the crot if I shoot him
no cell phones no devices no TVs my screens
more greens bars Till by the third day my
devil children want to kill each other the
question is is he a traitor definitely look at
him [__] snap my toothbrush in half now I own
nothing that was great delivery it's okay
pretty pissed about this whole fronzi thing
kind of love that kid so who we killing over it
it's kind of like Jeremy rener from the town oh
password protected hate guess and passwords
about to hate it more F set it up so we get
three guesses in 2 minutes or the drives
a race wow passwords come from deep down
what was Fran's thing what was he known for
just smash the keyboard and see whatever yeah
Pittsburgh Pirates Steelers that that sandwich
place where they put the fries on brothers
that was it yeah but not Pittsburgh in and of
itself it was his loyalty to it still led the
1110th after all these years taught his kid
our slogan what's his kid's birthday loyalty
is a byproduct where does it come from hero
worship France respected someone he couldn't
be dissuaded got to be a sports guy Davis was
the greatest musician ever France was loyal to
what he respected that's it Roberto Clemente
about Willie starel did Willie starel die in
a plane crash Deliverance supplies to earthquake
victims it's Clemente no it isn't who would use
a device like this did he put like a number
or a character who did fron respect more than
anyone any ball player any artist who did he heo
worship a the kid started cutting his hair like
you talking like you following you around
he wanted to be you reach started eating 12
chickens a day the doctor said you got to stop
working out it's too much for a skeleton to
handle a oh wow don't go get in a big head
you know his head's way too small for that big
relatively speaking he probably should even it out
you're booked for your flight to Denver enjoy your
trip thank you I certainly will damn this guy's
going everywhere I like to go yeah man Andrew
McBride Andrew McBride Alan Mason Alejandra Mendes
Alexander mopis just a list of names all starting
with the initials am all aliases you keep the same
initials so your signature never has to change
just an A&M with a squiggle after it no matter
which pseudonym you're using damn good idea really
smart well whatever this [__] is it was enough
to get bronze killed your room's trashed and God
knows whatever else we don't know about these guys
aren't shy about getting aggressive this guy's
one cigarette away from being Constantine none of
on10th are reachable reachable we send a Christmas
card to Swan every year think he lives in Queens
now I'll have Lily check our holiday mailer list
you really are domesticated I didn't get a holiday
mailer casting is well done I just I realized in
this very moment like oh I really believe the
history between Reacher and this other guy
yeah what happens when reer gets a whole
team you smell that that's a body I'll
take the [Music] upstairs someone going to
be nailed to a wall with their nuts missing
again o ooh caller says Maisy call is a dog
oh my God take the toilet B dry whoa Swan
would never let a dog die of thirst only
way he doesn't come home is if he couldn't
come home like the first season this is the
house of that guy who wasn't watering his dog
oh yeah what are you thinking I'm thinking
there's someone hellbent on taking out the
special investigators but you don't mess
with them and they're coming after us good
let's go let's
go hell yeah damn dog I think we should just
read the Wikipedia and what happens in the book
and then make predictions yeah I think you
know what I think going to go on limb here
I think the person responsible at the end of
the day is going to be a character we haven't
met yet he just is so buff many of you guys know
most of my days are a couple of hours of filming
and then most of the time it's dedicated to
like editing and a bunch of other computer
work often accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours
a day and on top of that comfort food is like
my life's biggest Vice but as many of you also
know working out and getting healthier has been
a massive component for me this year in particular
so in this Whirlwind I have found myself a perfect
Ally for quick healthy meals America's number
one meal kit a meal kit that I have subscribed
to prior to ever agreeing and working with them
so yes this is a genuine testimony and that is
of course for hello fresh and hellofresh is
in just about ease about bringing health and
flavor to your doorstep in this holiday season
forget about the stress of planning meals for
your healthc conscious friends friends like
me who will breede down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's unhealthy so
with hello fresh I'm looking forward to hosting
holiday dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best part the
variety it is incredible I'm pescatarian so they
have these delicious meals just like djon onion
crunch salmon over lemon broccoli spaghetti and
from one more plant-based days the vegan Maple
carrot power bowls they aren't just meals they're
culinary Adventures I learned the word culinary
during a long day the last thing I want to do is
spend a while cooking and that's where helloof
Fresh's 15-Minute Meals are a lifesaver they're
quick nutritious and Oho tasty perfect for my
non-stop lifestyle so why not join me in making
this holiday season both health conscious and
delicious with hellofresh with over 45 recipes and
seasonal add-ons to choose from every week there's
always something new to try and here's something
to cheer about go to hellofresh.com reject free
and use code reject free for free breakfast for
life is that accurate that sounds way too good
to be true there's no way that can be true go to
hellofresh.com reex free and use code reject free
for free breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box as long as your subscription is active
tag your hellofresh creations with # hellofresh
piic and @ hellofresh and let's cook up some
fun and healthiness reject Nation remember it's
America's number one meal kit hey reject Nation
you know running real rejects is an incredible
journey is something I am truly grateful for but
I got to be real with you for one second here
managing the business side especially taxes to
put it lightly is incredibly overwhelming it's
like navigating a maze without a map and that's
where our sponsor rocket money comes in a sponsor
when approached I was so excited to work with
because I kid you not just last month I started
using rocket money cuz I needed to sort out this
financial puzzle and honestly it's been quite eye
openening not just for taxes but boy oh boy that
whole cliche of this app is true I discovered
apps and subscriptions I have been paying for
that I had not used in ages it is like finding out
you've been leaving lights on in a room that you
never use so yes rocket money isn't just another
app it's like a freaking Financial Guardian Angel
it finds and cancels those forgotten subscriptions
monitors your spending and even battles to lower
your bills thank God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned money like I
try I really try to be on top of my expenses
rocket money they show me blind spots with a
simple tab I can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of negotiating with
customer services a relief my goodness to put it
into perspective rocket money has helped over 5
million users save an average of $720 a year
that's more than just numbers it's a piece of
mind so I invite you my fellow rejects in taking
control of your finances so go ahead visit rocket
money.com rejects once again that's rocket
money.com rejects let's save together rocket
money.com rejects I really do stand by this app
thank you for partnering with us yeah so I know
there's other episodes out for this but let's
talk about this John what did you think about our
return to Reacher it's good to be back in Reacher
territory in a new uh setting and whatnot I I
am looking forward to to how the setting uh it's
again we've started off in New York it seems like
there's at least a potential that we might stay
there in the first season we were so immersed in
the atmosphere of margrave and I hope that we can
get you know more of just that unique atmosphere
again um but yeah I don't know it's just great to
be back in and among the characters of this world
it's a lot of setup and stuff like that we're just
meeting the key players and getting the lay of the
land yeah um so you know I mean I I feel like this
is a good starting point for this season I'm not
like oh my God this is among the top episodes of
Jack Reacher but uh but I'm thrilled you know this
gave me a lot of the things I would hope for upon
re-entry and now I'm just excited to see how the
mystery grows and and grabs me and pulls me in
with the blend of personal and badassness yeah
yeah I mean I know we're talking about most people
prob just watch the first they what they releas
three yeah um and most people probably already
watching finish the other two by now um so I'll
keep whatever slight criticisms or concerns uh
tempered because I'm like well let's just see
they released a few out on top for a reason right
yeah uh but for a premier episode a great just
return for Allen richson again uh love the guy so
much and he uh that loneliness in the past couple
years he has significantly buffed up compared to
Jack reach or never go back that's sophomore entry
in Tom Cruz entry um it's it was it's fun because
in that movie they had the whole he walks up to a
guy in a car window smashes it yeah like nobody's
business and and they open with this one this is
the sophomore one but this is way better already
than all of that yes was a terrible movie but I
I loved I love I love the fact that we're getting
him and neie uh neie right you don't pronounce the
G uh him and and neie partnered up together and
just thinking about how they are evolving Jack
from the first EP first season he's he's he's kept
more at at a distance and at a mystery and then
oh you're compelled by the personal relationship
between him and his brother and even though he's
kept at arms length you're like I'm gravitated
towards this buff mysterious Wanderer because
clearly he is feeling the anguish of the loss
of his his brother and now they're keeping that
loss going uh with other brothers and sisters uh
the ones that he served with together but he was
also the leader of and it's an interesting um
relationship of sorts because while he whilst
he was the leader he wanted to be seen as an
equal it seems like you know like yeah if I
if I give a command you got to obey the command
however Hees like don't call me major don't call
me sir we are we are equals here and and trust my
judgment but don't fear my rank and much it seems
like everyone really looked up to him the one who
died is the one who most wanted to be him is the
one who most looked up to him and last season he
wanted to be so much like his brother and now he
has to it starts off with avenging the one who
uh wanted to be like him the most and so it's
it's cool like Dove tale of a story so I think I
feel like storytelling Wise It's appropriate to go
down this path and then to get these flashbacks
flushing out his time in the military fleshing
out his time as a major I think is really cool
there there's a lot of interesting ingredients
that I'm excited to see how the recipe ultimately
Cooks by the end and uh action violence yeah all
strong stuff I do think that it would be kind of a
a mistake to compare the um the the first episode
of like because your pilot like you really got to
make a bang and you know uh but then for a first
episode of a season two where you're airing a few
on the same day you you already have the audience
his faith of like well let's just play it out you
know yeah where like in the in season one you got
to like really got to hook you on that first
episode cuz that pilot was like near perfect
right yeah and it's got to be like a little short
film almost yeah yeah where whereas like the so
I'm trying to understand some of the stylistic
choices a little bit better so I'm like okay so
we're in the flashbacks of the military we're in
green it makes sense army people all right I got
it and then we're in the blue of the New York New
York Vibe all right sweet I get it we in La we're
in that yellow totally so I'm trying to understand
the visual language a little bit I don't know if
it's just like neat cinematography choices of
what they're doing but you know the music was
something that was so integral to last season uh
of of something that created such an atmosphere to
it and like the the soundtrack was was completely
intentional and in tune with the character as well
and here I'm trying to just kind of grasp I don't
know if I'm overthinking it but the shows kind of
made me pay attention to the music considering
what they did in the first season of like what
are these tracks you know like well do the tracks
have any meaning like how they had in last season
you know it does make me wonder what the shape of
this season is going to be like just because this
episode is more I guess by comparison to the first
season I thought just overall they demonstrated a
nice balance of like here are some are like
thoughtful character-based scenes that will
tie back around to the theme or to the mystery
or whatever it is and and and namely among those
things they had that thread of Jack uh and his
you know like cultural anthropological interest
inic music and like come into this region to learn
stuff about such and such a singer and it's like
those those are character ear marks that I thought
really fun and enjoyable and I like that this thus
far has that same kind of yeah vibrant uh you know
assembled soundtrack but it does make me wonder
like this felt a little bit more like an episodic
show where the first season had a a really nice
blend of I mean it's obviously it's a very
serialized mystery um but I don't know that that
one felt it carried itself almost like a limited
series in a way whereas this one at least just
at the outset this episode felt like more of a
part of like an ongoing Series in a different way
um so yeah it's like it's not like it's totally
different or anything like that but it's much more
at least at the outset I think kind of focused in
on the plot and these people and it makes sense
because they're so personal to Jack but it is it
does make me curious because the first season yeah
had so much of he's just meeting all these new
people and that gives it all this flavor with the
mystery and he had that exchange with the girl in
the pawn shop um but that's the only kind of real
like we're interacting with local flavor you know
have you seen The Equalizer movies I've seen the
first one I think okay so in the first equalizer
movie I would like and that's kind of the first
season Reacher where so much of you learning about
the characters as the other characters learning
about him like this guy is Unstoppable killing
machine and he's a hyper genius and who is he
yeah and then and equalizer 2 is when it gets more
introspective you're more from Reacher you're more
from uh Denzel's perspective in that movie and it
becomes more of a character study of him and the
now you're just you're in on the know of of who
Jack Reacher is in this season so I kind of think
that's what they're doing here yeah first season
he is more of a mystery so you're looking at him
from the perspective of a lot of these other
characters and then this season immediately is
just kicking off with we're we're with him and
now we're getting more personal with him we're
seeing what these other relationships the his
friendships are like the communal experience with
Reacher is like he's getting the team is getting
back together even though they don't want to get
back together for like Reunion yeah yeah they're
getting back together for uh a very specific cause
and and uh it's going to be rooted in in Vengeance
and there's something linked to their past of
something they've discovered before whatever
yeah so yeah like it's it there are aspects of
this that I that very much remind me actually of
equalizer too and and uh and I I guess I'm just
waiting to see how the Ensemble fully flashes out
because that was one thing the pilot did in the
last one was they made every character like really
intriguing right off the toally and and an overall
Aura we here we were cutting around to like New
York Los Angeles and flashbacks and so there's
yeah there's an established tone that we that
I think just needs a little bit time to fully
settle and breathe and then we will have a better
crisp understanding and focus of what to zero in
on but uh but you know we got seems like we got a
villain set up with Robert Patrick at least what
it looks like looks like we got a villain set up
with that one dude who's with passports oh yeah
the am guy yeah yeah and then we have uh I like I
like I I love the actress who plays Neely I think
she's a great actress and I like the other guy I
forget his name already but I like the other guy
yeah he he's I I can't the show could go either
one or two ways like they're they're teasing him
to be the guy who's like a traitor or they want
you to think he's the traitor because he seems
like he be the obvious one exactly totally uh but
I I I really have no clue and and uh that's going
to be yeah that's going to be a big part of the
fun and I imagine the more of the people if we
are if there are more survivors of uh you know
the special investigators out there you know
it'll only be more and more interesting I hope
to a get to know them see what they reveal about
Reacher and B I don't know I mean it if we do meet
more of him it could be any one of them you know
involved somehow CU to your point it does feel
a little bit more straightforward yeah and not
as much of the unique voice and flavor yeah this
feels a little bit more like oh what I imagined a
Jack Reacher show would be like yeah when I was
told there' be a show yeah the first season and
then we watched it I was like so much better
than I thought yeah this is good but it's not
but uh there is a special unique kind of voice it
transcends being an investigative procedural show
by having such a great flare for tone atmosphere
and characters yeah and I can see all the pieces
of that here but yeah I think it is partly because
we are going so many places in this first episode
and because we do already know Jack uh at least
you know to a a fair enough extent yeah I could
see how maybe it'll take a minute hopefully maybe
by episode two even just to kind of just to get
that sensibility back because because it does
excite me to be like okay so we did that with
Mar gev and we really immersed in that environment
what's it going to be like to do that in New York
well yeah I mean New York and La that's kind of
it's just general popul is Metropolis yeah yeah
yeah so it's like how is that how are we going
to get that more unique we're small town it's
it's intimate you know yeah there's yeah there's
that natural sense of atmosphere and personality
just by being there you know yeah so much stuff
takes place in metropolitan cities and uh this
whole review can be rendered pointless why
but that's that's the thing is when you if
this was like the only one they released we could
probably talk for longer yeah no but excited I'm
going to cut us short because I'm like there's
already another episode it so let's just see if
anything we saying is anything we have to even be
concerned I'm excited regardless yeah guys what
you think about the episode leave your thoughts
down below uh think you all been support us on
patreon pick a name any I'm feeling who am
I feeling today I'm feeling Ricardo Martinez
Ricardo Martinez you know what you're getting
for Christmas this year you are going to get a
hot air balloon that's right my friend a hot air
balloon at your disposal because you did great
things for our country and now you got to get the
hell out of here get out Dodge let's face it man
your service here done it's only getting worse
for it's getting worse it's getting disgusting
and it's time for you to find a better place
to live that'll make you feel a lot more merry
at this time of year I'm thinking I I don't
know why just off the top of my head Mexico
sure Puerto Rico uh Brazil uh Peru downtown
LA Chinatown Glendale the valley o there's
so many weener po Loco I was doing Spanish oh
hey sorry take it back did not pick up on the
joke did you I was doing satirical racism I mean
Del Taco Cal racism is a trademark of my humor
of course and obliviousness is a trademark of
mine you just took it in a completely different
direction yeah Ricardo you can travel anywhere
in this hot balloon it doesn't a weer nals man
you can go anywhere you want a hot air balloon is
an anti- parachute so jump into life man yeah and
then you're going to crash into a sleigh and guess
it's going to be there a freaking Rabbi oh killed
Santa and it's going to create a whole store of
controversy my God and then either Ricardo or the
rabbi has to take over for being Santa to cover
it up and either version is entertaining whilst
whilst running the synagogue Yeah Christmas and
hanuka are going to be fused together through
the spirit of uh capitalism thanks Ricardo
you did you did your country [Music] great